what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and big news in the
marvel universe today it looks like
another person from the netflix marvel
series could be joining us in the mcu
alongside of daredevil that is the
punisher specifically john bernthal's
punisher the perfect punisher really
which is great news now you may have
heard this news today that the punisher
is returning getting his own series and
this is actually coming from a disney
actor and is one of the actors that
appeared in some of these marvel netflix
series this is coming from rosario
dawson who of course plays claire in the
daredevil series and keep in mind and
this is important plays ahsoka tano in
star wars which is owned by disney and
of course marvel is owned by disney as
well now we'll dive into this and this
is absolutely exciting news but you may
have heard the counter news to this of
her saying that oh she doesn't really
know but what i think is that she's
actually just trying to cover it up and
i do believe that the punisher is
returning and rosario dawson did indeed
reveal that and i also do think that
some of the other defenders are going to
be returning as well and be brought into
the mcu to give us an mcu defenders
which we will talk about in this video
and of course if you love marvel be sure
to subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest news now there have
been rumors going around a while now
that jon bernthal's punisher would be
returning jon was going to reprise his
role as the punisher and now he was
going to be brought into the mcu now
when we first started to hear about
these rumors it was a while ago and we
weren't really sure however since then
marvel studios during san diego
comic-con that happened a couple of
weeks ago announced a daredevil disney
plus series with charlie cox returning
to play matt murdock aka daredevil and
guess what it's 18 episodes long the
longest disney plus series that has been
revealed today and this gave us
confirmation that marvel studios was not
afraid to bring those characters over
from the netflix series and bring them
into the mcu yes charlie cox appeared as
matt murdock and spider-man no way home
but we weren't really sure if that was
some sort of a fan service or if matt
murdock was indeed now in the mcu for
good but marvel studios answered that
question for us and now all of a sudden
all of these rumors seem to have a
little bit more merit because there were
rumors about daredevil returning before
and then there were rumors about the
punisher returning now daredevil's here
and it looks like the punisher is right
around the corner and it looks like
rosario dawson has confirmed that for us
yesterday during a panel at the chicago
comic and entertainment expo rosario
dawson seemingly dumped a huge punisher
bomb on us stating that she heard he was
returning and she was really excited
because that's the only show that her
character claire did not appear in
here's what she specifically said and i
quote i hadn't heard that announcement
but i found out yesterday that the
punisher was happening again so i feel
like it's my second chance because
that's the only one of the shows i
wasn't in and i love john bernthal so
let's all make it happen collectively
guys so this statement right here means
a little bit more than just coming from
a random person because rosario dawson
like i said does work for disney she is
filming the ahsoka tano series right now
she is around disney people disney
executives all of the time and she just
came out and said that she heard that
john bernthal was coming back now one
thing that she did not specify was that
if he's going to come back and maybe
make a cameo let's say in the daredevil
series or if he's going to be getting
his own show because right now there are
several projects that he could appear in
he could definitely appear in the
daredevil show but he could also appear
possibly in she-hulk he could definitely
appear and be associated with daredevil
in the show after all it does seem like
they are somewhat introducing the what
kevin feige calls the street side of the
mcu in this show at san diego comic-con
right after the hall h panel in an
interview with mtv kevin feige said we
have the street level with the newly
announced daredevil series and
spider-man going into the street level
as well so actually expect a spider-man
daredevil team up in the future but if
the punisher is coming into the mcu he
is definitely going to be on that street
level as well and matt murdock is a
lawyer as well and of course he's
daredevil so there would be many
different ways for the punisher to
appear in the she-hulk series he could
be connected to daredevil he could be
connected to matt murdock on a legal
side and if by the end of the series
she-hulk is going to start representing
superheroes and people of the sort well
it's not that hard to thread the
punisher in there however my hopes are
for an actual punisher series and i do
think if they are going to bring the
punisher into any other series it
probably is going to be daredevil first
much like we're seeing daredevil in
other series and movies before he gets
his own series i'm thinking that's going
to happen with the punisher we see him
show up and she hulk maybe maybe we see
him show up in the daredevil series and
then he gets his own series and make no
mistake jon bernthal wants to return to
play the punisher he has publicly stated
that a few times but let's talk about
what rosario dawson said after the fact
that she stated that the punisher was
returning later after the panel on
twitter she tweeted i can't be trusted
getting intel from fans during signings
is iffy apparently my bad i get excited
confirmation is key when you're told
what you want to hear now i don't really
buy this this kind of seems like a thing
where marvel was like yo what the heck
we told you that in confidence you
weren't supposed to say anything about
that perhaps rosario dawson thought that
it was public information at this point
since the daredevil series had already
been announced and she's a professional
actress and has done a lot of comic cons
and i know that she's heard a ton of
rumors and has been asked about a ton of
rumors so i don't think rosario dawson
would simply state something as fact
that she heard from a fan at a signing
this kind of seems like a cover-up to
make it seem like she didn't just spoil
the fact that the punisher is returning
because i actually think that a good
majority of those netflix characters are
going to be in the mcu in some way shape
or form at one point in time and what i
mean by that is they may not get their
own series but they could cameo in other
shows or movies it does seem very clear
at this point with kevin feige
establishing that there is going to be a
street level side of the mcu that there
are going to be street level characters
like daredevil like spider-man like the
punisher like jessica jones like luke
cage like all of the rest of those
characters that we know and love it does
seem like there is going to be somewhat
of a defender's team in fact there's
even been rumors that some of these
defenders could actually appear in the
echo series which makes sense we know
daredevil is going to be appearing in
that series as well we know kingpin is
going to be returning and is going to be
the villain of that series it makes
sense that another defender could
possibly be in that show and at the same
time i also think they could be building
this entire thing up for kingpin to be a
major villain and the defenders and
spider-man have to go up against him and
possibly a real sinister six which is
something that i know fans have been
waiting for for a very long time and we
really are right now in a golden age for
the mcu i know a lot of people have not
really enjoyed phase four so far but if
you think about it disney and marvel
studios now have all of the rights to
almost all of the characters we have all
of the fox properties back with the
x-men the fantastic four with deadpool
and they have all the rights to the
netflix characters the defenders jessica
jones daredevil the punisher luke cage
iron fist kingpin they have the rights
to all these characters back again that
they can and are using in the mcu the
only one that we're really questioning
right now is the hulk we know that the
distribution rights are held by
universal studios however that could
have changed at some point in time and
we just may not know about it but
regardless the hulk can be used in
team-up films so marvel studios really
does have access to any and all of the
characters that they want right now and
it looks like they have every intention
on using all of these characters we're
getting the fantastic four we're getting
the mutant soon we've already gotten
daredevil i think it's only a matter of
time until we do finally see the
punisher and perhaps some of the other
defenders as well but hey let me know
what you think about all of this in the
comments down below and how excited
would you be if john bernthal returned
as the punisher don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest news for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof